schule studium beruf der stress steigt
überhaupt immer mehr leistung wird
gefordert
allein bei den studenten putscht sich
mittlerweile jeder fünfte künstlich auf
vielen reicht kaffee als fitmacher nicht
millionenfach werden medikamente
missbraucht illegale und erlaubte
heimlich eine studentin die anonym
bleiben will
ja ich hatte da so eine ganz spezielle
prüfung die ich immer wieder versammelt
habe und die euch bestimmt jetzt 67 mal
geschrieben und weil ich immer nur
relativ müde war und wie keinen klaren
gedanken fassen konnte habe ich mir
gedacht das probiere ich doch dann
einfach mal aus verbessert hirndoping
tatsächlich das denken
klaus lieb hat erstmals getestet wie es
bei höherer leistungsanforderungen wirkt
er ließ schachspieler gegeneinander
antreten okay wir glauben aktuell dass
diese substanzen die maximal die
konzentration die aufmerksamkeit die
wahrheit verbessern können das sieht man
insbesondere wenn gesunde menschen nach
schlafentzug diese substanzen einnehmen
dann ist durchaus so dass sie auch mehr
aufnehmen können
dass sie allerdings so als sich
intelligent der klüger schlauer werden
das glauben wir nicht
die probanden bekamen entweder ritalin
modafinil koffeintabletten oder ein
wirkungsloses scheint die come and ein
placebo was sie bekamen erfuhren sie
nicht
noch ist die studie nicht endgültig
ausgewertet
doch die wissenschaftler konnten schon
sehen die spieler wurden wach
aufmerksamer schneller
doch der unterschied zwischen echtem
hirndoping und dem scheinmedikament war
überraschend gering
wir haben keine pille die völlig sicher
ist im vollen effekt hat und deswegen
uns jetzt hier in höchster
leistungsebene katapultiert sondern
werden die situation dass wir substanzen
haben die vielleicht ein bisschen mehr
machen als placebo aber dabei relativ
viele nebenwirkungen und auch
langfristige risiken haben denn die
substanzen bringen die botenstoffe im
gehirn durcheinander
man braucht immer mehr der stoffe zur
droge auf kopfschmerzen und
schlaflosigkeit folgen halluzinationen
depressionen totalausfall
dennoch scheint der siegeszug der mittel
unaufhaltsam dabei halten die substanzen
gar nicht was sie versprechen
im spielfilm ohne limit wird mit einer
wunderdroge alles möglich ist sehr schön
dargestellt er in dem film das hier so
eine art reizüberflutung stattfindet so
ganz viele kanäle praktisch geöffnet
werden durch die substanz und ist dann
in der lage eben auf dem bildschirm alle
zahlen gleichzeitig zu sehen die ganzen
tabellenkalkulation in
höchstgeschwindigkeit wahrzunehmen also
erscheinen im prinzip scheint es
ermöglicht zu sein aber durch eine pille
doch mit dem jetzigen möglichkeiten die
wir jetzt nicht zu erreichen
in ihrer studie stellen die forscher
fest der nutzen von hirndoping steht in
keinem verhältnis zu den
gesundheitlichen gefahren und die
hirnleistung kann sich sogar verringern
also wenn ich sowieso schon gut und
leistungsfähig bin dann wird meine
leistung durch diese substanzen eher
schlechter als besser während es bei
denen die nicht so gut erholt sind und
nicht so leistungsfähig sind da kann man
ein bisschen was aus
doch der preis ist hoch der
wissenschaftler klaus lieb von der pille
fürs gehirn grundsätzlich ab